nous sommes les faire de la liberté
ce royaume a toujours été protégé par
les abos ji
une armée de guerrière constituée de
femmes rejetés par la société
pouvoir les rejoindre est un grand
honneur
alors
[Musique]
hulu
quel boîtier
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux que nous
ils ne savent pas que le mal arrive tu
veux que je fasse entrer montrent un
plan coeur il faut se battre pour
certaines causes
[Musique]
depuis notre enfance on ne parle des ago
ji vous être une guerrière tu dois tuer
tes larmes entraîne toi dur combat avec
acharnement
craindre à aucun homme et tout redoutera
aucune douleur
nos cicatrices sont notre fierté
elle raconte comment nous sommes devenus
plus forte comment nous avons survécu
pas trop ce qui nous réduisent en
esclavage
nous sommes les pets de la liberté
[Applaudissements]
là tu te souviendras deux mois
[Musique]
tous les fronts
terriblement
[Musique]
sauf à zillisheim
des images
à ce moment là
[Musique]
canal
pour l'heure
[Musique]
léo et sa king
le coach
les
oies
aux mains d'argent
m
hyundai
et aussi
haïti
[Musique]
je suis
à
las la paix
yasmina et les polluants
déçue la sélection
un tel procès
bingo
[Musique]
c'est
propre
chauny de jazz band rock
pop se
[Musique]
pose
et ce sommet est le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nombre
est ce que tu te souviens seulement
encore de ce que l'on ressent quand on
vit loin tous béziers la vente à changer
[Musique]
une nouvelle norme puissante que ce que
tu peux imaginer
ils tueraient des milliers de gens pas
de combat rien que la mort
arrêt et rêvant tient possède des armes
qui peuvent détruire des cités entières
dubaï à ce rallye
nous avons maintenant une arbre qui nous
rend inverse aucune religion ne les
arrêtera la brutalité une solution plus
élégante je suis votre reine
[Applaudissements]
mes soeurs nous a pourchassé pendant 17
années elle ne va pas s'arrêter
maintenant
on aurait plutôt que de laisser quoi que
ce soit à rien toi ou à nos enfants
mais jamais dû me battre pour ma
couronne
bientôt elle sera forgé sur la braise et
les flammes de la guerre
et elle fera de moi une reine ressuscité
[Musique]
je pense que tu sais ce que tu as fait
frappe encore
peu détruit celui pour lequel vous avez
été plus souple
[Musique]
on a toujours rêvé de devenir samouraï
seul problème c'est un chien les siens
pascual samouraï dégâts chez moi c'est
un passe à la trappe
on dirait que tu as besoin d'un
professeur presse que je perde retrouver
sains
et sans toit
et n'irait pas un bouquin pour apprendre
à devenir samouraï tu penses à samouraïs
pour les lui louer non parce que ce
serait pour des nues traverse la rivière
achats retombe toujours sur ses pattes
pas si je vous ai dit mais je suis pas
chaud
on peut passer directement au moment où
je te fais un bon ben moi c'est
maintenant que je préfère
qu'il faut qu'ils protègent au nom de la
loi je t'arrête
par le réalisateur du roi lion et lui
rappeler
non d'un caniche constipé qu'est ce qui
se passe ici le 12 octobre ça va barder
plus
largement
comment on fait pour entrer maintenant
bon faisons réessayer
et voilà le travail le film le plus fun
des vacances
la peur n'existe que dans ton esprit et
un petit peu aussi dans mon kimono
samouraï académie qui aurait cru qu'une
armée de chats aimerait autant les
flageolets
on
n'est pas rendus au cinéma le 12 octobre
j'avais rien prémédité du tout à cette
soirée ça faisait bien longtemps que
j'avais pas embrasser une autre femme on
va boire un verre des deux mais je
ressens l'envié irrésistible de faire
l'amour avec toi
ça ça va vite mais j'ai pourtant tous
les faits comme il faut j'ai parlé de ma
femme de mes enfants et que j'étais sans
doute pas bons plans ah non ça tu me l'a
pas dit
simple on ressent une attirance l'un
pour l'autre on se plaît on fait pas de
plans sur la comète
arrête avec cette idée de trompeta sam
tulle m bah oui bah voilà donc ça veut
dire que tu la trompe pas nous recevoir
pour d'autres choses
[Musique]
on va profiter du temps qui nous reste
on va se faire du bien sans penser au
futur
je veux prendre une douche avec moi non
je veux garder 32
m
[Musique]
pourtant comment ça content je veux dire
que tu es bien gros faisait que bien j
-cr autres
[Musique]
contente toi non
tu pourrais l'être inciter bien
en ce que je veux dire c'est que je suis
content de vivre ce que j'ai la
[Musique]
même si on ne fait rien pour moi te voir
c'est déjà sexuelle
[Musique]